theer flyer that's ripped in by Jenner now
proov with it bans on it and he gets it again
here's goodro back to the line on the wing and
Bennington got over and made that save on kov
who's puck now Johnson gets it seen pass tipped
by Shen and pressure by Columbus Andrew Peak
again and now covered by dinnington so casber
C is on though he is skating and he said this
morning he expects to play When the blues come
back from the allstar break that's great news
still wearing that jaw protector he's going
to lose it after this game as he goes to the
all-star break now rinsky a shot and a save
by Bennington now kicked Along by blle he's
wearing a drop protector he gets it in front
blle a good chance and the Blue's first shot
on goal by blade BL has picked up eight points
in his last nine games now break for the Blu
dropped off to shin and he waits shoots it and
a pad save by mikin he comes in Thomas thought
about shooting get some help there from Kyu now
to Kastle hard pass to KW waiting shooting one
that was knocked down by kessle now goodro comes
in steers it around the Dasher and then Jenner
Off the Wall shoots it another shot off the goal
post that hit the far post and a break for the
blues and here they come to Center Shen with s
the S now with the puck trickle off his stick
now steered back to crew and he waits find
Shan shoots it up high to save Byers leas
comes in front and then near the line kept in by
Olivier in front shot right on by Dan forth and
a save by Bennington on Justin Danforth now this
from the aolone Pro what does APR even stand for
here let me help there I got you a great deal
some things you should leave to the fros the
[Music] autopro.com so Face Off to the left
of Bennington scramble draw tipped to the
line and now on for wensky shoots it GL save
by Bennington Johnson tips it blocked by Ley
and the blues come back and a break for Shen
with sunquist the sunquist shorthanded and
it's save by mge leakin but nonetheless they
took care of business and talking about Oscar
sunquist what a fantastic pass by Braden shanon
just to get it over there to Oscar sunquist now
the jackets Come Back in Johnson here's a
pass in front for Ron backhander save by
Bennington that was in late December Johnson gets
it on the half wall baronov front
and a shot by Mao and that goes
high and Robert Thomas has 5 seconds left in his
minor R the draw dumped in by Paro and Thomas is
out of the box and the neighbors battles and
his own Bench Jackets Get It singer in front
and off the body of rosc and a save by bennon
and that was close now wasle to the line to G
Branson shoots it and a save that was tipped and
a great save by Bennington that was tipped on the
way through and now TP Koo again Cycles one for
Hayes at the line scandella shoots it and a pad
save by m Le and then Nathan Walker and the
cycle for D jenko to the line pero shoots it
Locker Sabers leakas and a big hit by tchenko
on cylinder and the puck to Center ice and now
rinsky works in backhander wide comes around to
Paro tip to Center and Hayes trying to dangle
in he waits now Waits some more finds Paro and
a drive and that goes wide hard shot there by
Faro over 100 milph gets it again shoots it right
on and a save by m lein now pressure by the blues
and then Ley to the net rebound off the padur
leaking all over rinsky blade trying to try it
free he does now blade back to cre he comes in
and a drive and that hit his own man I think and
trying to make a play and that was off a jacket
player and back out and then Tucker back in on
warnky that shot by rinsky to the St Louis line
now on to Jenner for PE a drive right on goal and
a save by Bennington on Andrew beak he's for Sho
Walker they played a direct game now Hayes gets
it WRA around comes in front they poke away and
M leens has it as and he can't pull the trigger
and lift it up by Ganson track down BYO check
though Jer with it right in and Jenner scores
crowd reacting like they don't think it went in
so we'll have to get a good look here as Jenner
gains that middle ice takes that shot now we
see it rattle around but you you just can't see
for sure get one more look at it here yeah that
might have hit the bar it rattles around I think
off both bars and here we'll get a good look
at it here no that's no goal is a no goal that
is no goal they're going to look at this yeah no
goal you know it's interesting Jamie the referee
was right there and right away signal goal yeah
and you know in his defense those shots are hard
jackets g a lot of room as they set up a traffic
Center ice now Ley checked there by barchenko he
wait shoots it on goal and ack save by Bennington
now blade trying to charge in there to the middle
trying to get through a couple of blue jacket
sticks kept in by Krug here's Krug shoots it on
goal and a save by m lein right at the buzzer
and a good save there that comes around fro
has to hustle and does to keep it alive Thomas
stands on the centering pass and a shot right
on goal by bunich after the jackets coughed it
up and the rebound is played all the way down
well paavo BR DAV has had a couple of real good
opportunities throughout this game and that was
another one right there now Breo nice pass
for kessle and the rookie hits the line for
Jake neighbors shoots it off the pad of M lein
and the blues get it back neighbors there now
with sunquist ahead with Shen at the line Shen
has numbers at the net waiting now to the net
rebound shot neighbors robw Byers leans oh what
a chance there the Blue's best chance tonight
from Jake neighbors great opportunity there still
don't know how that ended up staying out of the
net and the blue shoot it down the ice and
Jake Bean back in his own Zone up the middle
rosic drops it and a shot wide now it's
warnky back the other way back in a bit
shot rebound and Bennington got over made
the save on Jenner he shot it wide yeah
he shot it high and wide now the Blue's at
the line they get in clean Le Thomas waiting
and he spins around and the puck in front
intercepted by Columbus and a good road to
wensky pass in front the score baronov
under OD man break and he makes it one
nothing Blue Jackets get on the board here
first with the Scorpion save on that one the
Johnny Gad here under the Stick of Tory KW
then warenski was jumping up from the blue
line he passed that over to ronov who makes no
mistake for Pavo davich nice pass to Thomas he
starts in now Robert Thomas back to crew
shoots it and a good save there by B Le
another shot by Thomas right on and a save by
B leens again and Tory KRW with seven to go on
goal and a save by ver leakin and the blues
are blanked for the second time this year